I felt like there was some sort of
record to break with getting a picture
with the most superheroes on one stage
so can we bring out the cast of
Wolverine Deadpool x-men apocalypse and
Fantastic Four please number one out and
then if someone could someone could come
take the picture that would be amazing
is there anyone no there's a barrier
there you can't
well sure Superman could just jump right
over uh is there anyone who could come
out and take the picture for us
I think I found I they have someone
backstage is going to come out and take
the picture for us can you send him out
so we can take this hey wait a minute
just wait one
I'm just pretty pissed I want to tell
you this is ridiculous
well I'm gonna take the picture and get
it over with you you think I can just do
cameos I'm one of the great
photographers and by the way all of you
are in charge I charge you with the
responsibility of writing to the Motion
Picture Academy and saying they need an
award for best cameo but we'll save that
do you have a cat who's got a camera
does anyone who's got the camera have a
camera someone else have a cat my camo
ash any kind of mascara there we are
sir
what's up
make it good remember I'm watching ya
okay my end
focus on me
but
take it off Chris all right no please no
applause all right here we go
here we go these are my people here we
go now that's the way to end a path you
guys thank you so much
I have been Chris Hardwick take a few
pictures and we'll see you in the rest
of the con
you